hello everyone
my name is tom um the seventh
they call me tom seven some of them and
um i'm just some guy
who did a funny project i'm like the
former
presenters and recovering academic uh
this is not an academic presentation but
i hope it is
still illuminating and entertaining for
you uh so
the topic of the talk is keep going back
over here
uh learn fun and play fun which is two
pieces of software i wrote
on a lark uh which automate the playing
of old video games
and the goal here is definitely not to
do this in a good way i'm not trying to
publish a paper uh i'm not trying to
um succeed at playing video games i
don't really care about rescuing the
princess
unless i do it with style yes
what
no it uh old video games i guess call of
duty is pretty old now
but um no this is this is specific to
the nintendo entertainment system
and video game systems that are very uh
small by
modern standards and i'll explain why
although the techniques conceivably
could apply to
call of duty in the far future so the
design goals here again is not to be
really good at the game but to do so in
an amusingly general
mathematically elegant and stupid
technique um away
and basically you may have seen this uh
this video there's a somewhat popular
video online and there's a follow-up
video
you can watch them and i encourage you
to those have
sort of better comedic timing maybe but
uh
and more of the same kind of stuff here
i know this is more or less a computer
science audience i hope and so i'm gonna
actually talk a bit about how the
algorithms work but there is a section
at the end
of um of it succeeding and failing in
humorous or perhaps impressive or
ways that make you despair so
and i think it's a little bit of a short
talk based on
my feelings so save your questions and
do ask questions at the end
okay i'll try to go slow this is a
really hard thing for me to go slow
i want to talk about sigbovich sickboy
so this work again is not like real
academic work
i just did it um for the fun of the hack
and if you like that kind of thing
sigbox so this was originally published
in sigbobic which is a conference we
have every year at cmu
and these are some of the titles of
former of projects that i did in the
past
wikipedia the free programming language
that anyone can edit it was a thing i
really built and you
this audience might actually like that
one maybe i should have talked about
that instead
what words ought to exist is sort of the
philosophical follow-on to the last talk
that we just saw
you keep dying um is a video game about
dying
a lot and uh who's the biggest douche in
sky mall is uh
applying some important techniques in
machine learning to figure out who is
the douchiest of them all
so do check that out and you know or
write a paper for it or whatever
but just so you get a sense of where i'm
coming from with this work
okay so the nintendo entertainment
system this is the best video game
system
certainly if you're my age you must know
that and if you're too yeah
yeah and if you're a call of duty player
just go back to the classics every once
in a while and understand where gaming
came from
what's awesome about the the nes given
that it stole so many years of my life
to me is how tiny this computer is so
it's the
ricoh 2a03 processors tiny processor you
could like look at the traces of the
transistors
with a magnifying glass that's how small
it is 2048 bytes of ram two kilobytes
this is 2048 pixels i probably should
have made this black and white because
there's actually red green and blue
uh color channels here so this is three
times the information content of a
nintendo
on the screen okay and it runs at 1.79
megahertz
so like roughly speaking my home
computer which is a beast can fit 32
million
nintendos in ram at once without
compression any fancy techniques 32
million
and runs what like 4 000 times faster
than that
on each of its 12 cores so like
this is what originally inspired me to
do to do this project
just the thought that like i was getting
all that entertainment out of this
joke of a computer by modern standards
what if i had
a really big computer doing all of that
stuff like in parallel or whatever
so uh some more primers about the
nintendo entertainment system so there
are
eight inputs which is so it's an 8-bit
processor uh it's no coincidence that
there are eight
inputs and so that's like the
essentially the entire space over which
we're going to search
for a single player just those eight
buttons
and yes that was the konami code in case
we're trying to figure it out um
and one of the really nice things about
having 2048 bytes of ram is programmers
just wrote these things in assembly very
straightforwardly and they
wrote programs where there's a global
variable called like
mario's x coordinate on the screen and
that's literally where it is it's at hex
address 86 and other stuff like
well the first level consists of a
series of screens
each stored in rom so there's a lot of
rom there's many many kilobytes of ram
maybe
mario's like 64 kilobytes of rom but the
ram is small
and so it would tell you which sort of
page in this level are you on and that's
stored at 6d
and there's other stuff like the
level you're on which is you know world
1-1 is world one
level one so those are stored in ram
somewhere the number of coins the number
of lives
not all of that stuff's on screen some
of it's on screen sometimes there's the
decimal representation
for the screen display sometimes there's
a hex hex
thing in memory but the important lesson
is these games were not written in a
fancy
way okay there's just a variable that
says how many coins you have
so the thought is like
what does it mean to win a game and i
want to do this in general for all games
and the simplest possible thing i could
think of would be
well these bites should be going up
because actually all the things i talked
about there
right like the level it's good if that
goes up the world it's good
you know coins want more coins right all
the time more lives
i even want my screen to get higher and
i want my x coordinate to get higher
right
so like if the ram is going up i must be
winning the game
which now you laugh but this is going
this is going to actually work
right and that's the that's the joke and
this is a little bit more complicated
actually it's a lot more complicated but
still i think pretty elegant um not
bites but sequences of bytes in
lexicographic orderings
so what do i mean by that well let's
just think about the world level pair
i go from one one to one two so that
bite went up then one three that went up
one four
but now actually four went down to one
but there's another bite
that went up which is my world but so as
long as i know if i'm thinking about the
world in a level together it's okay that
my level went back down to one because
my world went
off and that's the familiar i hope no
notion of a lexicographic
ordering and it generalizes so many
concepts in video games that are very
simple like super mario bros
like the pair of your world and level is
a really good predictor as we just
talked about
the world the level then the screen
number and then your x coordinate within
a screen
is also a really good metric for how far
you've gone or your lives and your coins
because when you get 100 coins you get
an extra life
or like the first second and third and
fourth bytes of a multi-byte
thing like your score no matter whether
it's in a
big or little or some kind of weird
interleaved in
uh endianness something like that so
it's nice right that you can
spell out a lot of metrics on a game's
progress
using lexicographic orderings on
locations of memory
so the idea is uh what if i could figure
out by watching a person play the game
it's going to be me
uh how what does it mean to win that
game and i could do that by
modeling it as these lexographic
sequences and then i can use that in
order to play the game automatically
okay so that's what i'm going to talk
about for the remainder of the talk
learn fun is that first part that's the
thing that's going to learn
what lexicographic orderings are mean
are for this game to be winning that's a
really awkward sentence that i apologize
for
and then the other half is going to use
those to play the game
so basically this is me playing super
mario brothers i record some
sequence of me playing for like a minute
and i produce those
uh those orderings they're not actually
those i don't know what they mean right
they're just going to be the addresses
that i observed having these properties
of going up
and this is why we're trying to close
the shades i designed for a darker room
there's some faint red text here which
is the uh
this is a weight so there's actually not
just the orderings but
they're weighted just for full
disclosure
and then i'm going to use those
objective functions to search for a
sequence of inputs that wins the game
and to be clear this search happens
offline conceivably if i had fast enough
computer i could do this and you could
just watch it happen
but this is kind of an overnight affair
it's not it's not absurdly slow and i'm
talking about like if i had
10 computers like mine that i could run
this real time
and so playfun takes those weighted
objective functions
and produces inputs that win the game or
jump in the pit you know
sometimes it does that and that was
something that it really did
so what do i mean by search um the title
of this paper in sigbovic
was the first level of super mario bros
is easy with lexicographic orderings
which we talked about and time travel
and this is the time travel part so and
this is this this is the reason why this
approach is least useful okay it
specifically requires that i'm able to
emulate the nintendo in order to know
what would happen if i did a specific
thing and the nintendo because it's a
simple computer i can just simulate it
on my computer
and i can save a state and i can try out
a series of inputs and see what would
happen
all right and that's not true of most
problems that we want to solve sadly
some problems so for example i have some
state here i am at the beginning
of world one one and here's the state
where i do nothing or the input where i
do nothing
and basically i just kind of stand there
and the goomba gets closer
and that's the state where i press the a
button and i start jumping up and i get
the coin
and i can take each of those and i can
explore them further
this is like assuming there's only two
possible inputs there's actually a lot
of inputs that i could
do at any given step so i have this
whole tree right
so i could search that tree and i could
say well here i've gotten down to some
state
how good is that state according to
those lexicographic orderings
compared to the first one or compared to
those other ones to decide
whether i'm making progress right
sadly um you can't use brute force you
can't just search this space right
so one second of gameplay is the frames
per second
to the two to the number of inputs
because i could press a
and right at the same time right so the
power set of those buttons
which is six to the 256 which is that
number
for one second and it's not even like i
just have to do that for every second
it's actually
the product of those so it's a
ridiculous number right there's no way
you could brute force this thing
so you have to be kind of smart about it
and in the rest of talk
i just want to tell you about how learn
fun works how playfun works
and then i'm gonna show you videos of it
um of it playing and the videos by the
way if you have seen this online i'm
gonna show you some new stuff
so uh hopefully it won't be all
repetition and taking 10 minutes
yeah this will be good i'm worried about
going too fast
so let's talk about learn fun learn fun
is the thing that produces those
lexicographic orderings
so the input is a series of rams a time
series of rams and i'm going to say rams
i know it sounds really wrong but it is
rams because it's like the ram at frame
one the ram at frame two the ram at
frame three
uh and those are pictures of like actual
super mario bros
rams in black and white this time and
the output is the like
the lexigraphic orderings i take about 4
000 frames in
and i output about 250 ordering so you
get a sense of what that's like
and this problem can be solved exactly
this is actually a nice mathematical
problem
in fact it it's a nice exercise if you
want to figure out how to do this but
i'm just going to belabor it
uh so basically what you do is you
non-deterministic
non-deterministically select an ordering
um
l this is a script l that's obeyed by
those rams which
by which i mean that like each ram is
less than or equal to the next ram
according to this ordering
and additionally there'll be some
properties that l will have it'll be
quote-unquote tight
and maximum i just made up those words
uh so
like if you're studying lexigraphic
orderings and you don't know what i'm
talking about
that's why um this is what this is what
i
take those to mean a tight one means
that every location in l so remember
l is like the world the level the x
coordinate and your coins or something
like that
it means that every location that's in l
was used at some point
in the in the process of those rams to
discriminate some pair of rams
because for example if i have a byte in
my input that's always zero like it's
just
you know whatever by 19 is always zero
then i could say yeah 19 is part of my
ordering but i don't have any evidence
that 19 is interesting
and it will be obeyed by all of those
rams because it will always be zero so
it'd always be less than or equal at
that byte
so i ensure that um somewhere i at least
saw the lives go up and that was the
only thing that went up
in order to make me think that these uh
memories are less than or equal to
so that's important otherwise you get a
bunch of bytes that are not useful in
your ordering
and then maximal maybe is not important
but i have this constraint
anyway which is that you can't add
anything else on the end in the least
significant position
and still be valid and tight so like you
have to have
exploited all of the memory addresses
that you know about
that are obeyed in this ordering in
order to be done
right sort of makes sense and uh the
algorithm
is this is like the one slide of the
algorithm um basically you're just gonna
take
a tight and valid l some any one
and you're gonna non-deterministically
extend it with some new location in its
lowest
least significant position until you
can't do that anymore which therefore
means that it's maximal right
by definition that we just talked about
and uh what we'll do is we'll start with
the empty sequence
because that is you know like basically
everything is going to be equal or
less than or equal to and um it is valid
because there's
of course everything is less than or
equal with the with the empty ordering
and it's tight
because a quantum for all quantifier
over the empty list is
uh trivially satisfied so a location x
extends
l if this is establishing tightness and
if you're very good at reading faint red
text you can see it says tight there and
valid there
spoiler alert um for
there must exist some pair of rams ri
and the next one are i plus one
where basically it's equal on the prefix
but this
particular um byte makes it strictly
less than so somewhere this had to be
the deciding factor
um and it's only the deciding factor if
that's equal in the prefix not less than
and then for all pairs uh if it's equal
on the prefix
then it has to be less than or equal to
and we're only talking again about
equality here because that's the nature
of lexicographic orderings
when the world has gone up i don't care
about anything that's less important
than that in the ordering for example
the level
level can do anything like go down if
the world went up okay
so that's a nice um that's a nice
algorithm and you can code it up and
you can get your undergrads to do it or
uh especially have a nice functional
programming language it's like it's a
breeze it's a delight to write
i use c plus plus like a chump because
uh first of all i'm a trump
but second of all i was working in uh
this emulator called
fce ultra which is written in c and so
like i didn't
i could have tried to bind ml bindings
or something for it but it's not that
bad
now some things to know about the
generation of these lexicographic
orderings
um this is me playing again and when i'm
playing this
game i don't always go strictly to the
right wright is winning for sure that's
the way you go in super mario brothers
every kid knows but like here i'm
struggling to get up to this uh to this
flower and i go back to the left
and this would the algorithm that i just
showed you would think
well most of the time he goes up but i
just found a place where this goes down
invalid can't be one of the orderings
and i graphed that over there
with uh it's i couldn't put x
the x coordinate on the y axis so it's
it's got a really strange into it
you get it you go left it's not um
strictly valid so what i do is i
actually chunk up the memory
i have a couple different approaches one
of them is just try the whole memory as
the input
but i can also look at for example just
the first tenth of the input
and look at orderings that are obeyed
there or i could look at every tenth
frame so that things that
sort of gradually go up over time but
are momentarily violated are likely to
be caught by one of these
thingies right and
uh yeah that was a reminder to myself to
fix that because that's not true but i
was
some way of producing the weights okay
so i also have to decide
because for example like let's say i
found an ordering that was obeyed for
these white stripes here
but in between there was like a real lot
of going left sorts of stuff
i would want that to count against that
ordering in a soft way
so there's some approach for weighting
them that this slide is totally
misleading about so i'm skip it
and this is a graph of these are
my inputs over time of playing super
mario brothers and each one of these
colors
is a different lexicographic ordering
that was produced by what i just talked
about
and they go up as you'd expect but there
are ones that are momentarily violated
so like this blue one this tl1 here goes
and then sort of vibrates
and then it's good again and so like it
probably was ignoring this section of
the game
when it was being trained but that's
good because you know
some points i'm swimming and swimming
might look a little different than
running and i still want to learn
about swimming okay
now we're going to talk about searching
then we're going to watch a movie
okay good searching for a sequence of
moves that maximize the objective
function so actually what i just talked
about is learn fun and that's
more or less the whole story it's a
simple program and that program
once it's done i can throw out
everything having to do with the game
like
i'll never again look at um you know the
pictures or anything like the sound or
anything on the screen
i'm really just looking at rams and in
fact only at the addresses that appear
in these lexographic orderings in order
to do the search
so this is the hard part of the program
and this is the part that
i spent most of my time on maybe
unwisely so the space is huge as we
talked about there's like
ridiculous exponents in there and 60
frames a second right
uh and it's mostly tree shaped so unlike
you know lots of game
search like chess for example you can
permute moves and get back to the same
state
in this the nintendo's got all sorts of
timers it's got the music
it's got pseudo-random number generators
in it so you basically never
it's not usually the case that if you
jump and then walk right you'll be in
the same
state as if you walked right and then
jumped right so it's basically a tree
simulating steps is actually fairly slow
it takes about 500 microseconds i know
that doesn't sound that slow but
um it's kind of slow so you have to be
careful to not simulate a step unless
you're going to use that output
and you want to keep making progress
because
i'm never going to actually rescue the
princess in this and i wouldn't even
know what rescuing the princess
is because the training data doesn't
contain that so i want to make sure that
it's playing the game and not just
being paralyzed looking for a good
solution when one when it can't find one
okay so that's like where this algorithm
kind of comes from
uh in other words you can't just use a
stars to throw something in for all i
know some academics have some
great way to do this and that's great
for them but i like to invent stuff
that's
fun right um
sound and everything so this was the
very first approach by the way
just pick this the input that makes the
objection functions go up the most on
the next frame and these are the
these are like what it's pressing so
it's just like
and and that's what mario does and it
just does that until the game ends
and probably somewhere someone's like
first player
[Music]
we'll see some more funny funny things
in a bit so
the algorithm looks like this basically
i you need a little bit more long-term
planning and the algorithm is kind of
the mix the typical mix of tactics and
strategy that you see in this kind of
thing right
so there's going to be some exhaustive
search over the tactics the things i'm
going to do very next right now
um what buttons am i going to press in
the next five frames and some like
planning of what am i going to do later
but again we have no idea what's
happening in the game so like forming a
high-level plan
is sort of ridiculous all we can do is
take two states and decide which one is
greater than the other
based on exographic ordering right okay
so what i do is i
have roughly 40 different random
sequences that are about 300 inputs
that's five seconds in length and i just
randomly generate those
i randomly generate them according to a
model that i'll mention a bit
then i'm going to do an exhaustive
search over some short sequences and use
those futures
to decide which of those which of those
next states
look good to me okay so you know in
chess for example if you want to
evaluate a chess state you can look at
the
the pieces on the board i don't get to
do that i don't understand the board
but you can at least simulate chess
moves like random play or something
and see what happens and i can do that
so i'm just simulating random play to
see how good a state is like am i about
to fall in a pit
and this has the prose that
it allows me to evaluate those
those states it allows me to maintain
some kind of coherence of the plan over
time because i'm looking like five
seconds in
ahead of time and it allows me to
reinforce and vary ideas that are that
show them to be good
okay and this one i'm going to try to
explain i think this is a new algorithm
i don't know basically so here's the 40
futures
imagine that this goes to f sub 40. and
it's
the future is just a series of inputs
okay um
and you're currently looking at some
state for example the beginning of super
mario brothers
and what we're going to do is we're
going to chop off the first five
inputs it's literally five of course you
could change that number if you wanted
of each of those sequences and those are
going to be called the nexts
so these are the things that i might do
next i'm going to just exhaustively
search over those
and i'm going to decide which one's the
best and then i'm going to do that and
the way i do that
is oh i also have to let's save the
tails everything that comes after those
next and we'll call those the tails
because we're going to use those in a
bit um so the goal is to pick the best
the best next and commit
to it and what i'll do is i'll take that
any one of them i would do this for all
of them
and i'm going to run it so now i'm in a
new state okay that's the result state
right makes sense in fact that's really
all i can do is run a state
i just shrank it and then for that frame
i'm going to take all of the tails for
all of the futures and i'm going to try
all of those out
given this state okay and i get what are
called the ends
all those different ends now i can do
things like say
is this state greater than this state or
is this state
greater than that state okay um
i'm sorry i have to keep walking back
there's this thing on the screen but i
like the dynamic
walking around and then
i'm going to choose the best result the
best next
uh according to whatever of those ends
is the max
so like the the best state that i can
get to given that and it's not like it
so it's not like an average
or anything like that and that's that
was unintuitive to me until i had a
realization this is kind of like okay so
for example
let's say i die in all of the states
except for one so like i'm
about to jump on some lava but in one of
them i like just barely eek it out
you might think that this is a dangerous
state and human would think of that as
pretty dangerous like don't go near the
lava
because random play tends to kill you
and i initially started that way but
what i actually changed it
what i realized is it's kind of like
mini max
right where you have an opponent except
you don't have an opponent because you
can make the goombas do anything you
want
by just exactly pressing the right way
so
as long as i have one good move it
doesn't matter if i'm gonna die in all
the rest of them
because nothing can ever force me to do
something to make a bad move in the
future
if i know a good move so it's really
just max over those over those results
and an important fact is that every
next is evaluated with its tail
from that first thing when we split them
up so i at least
will get to see again uh any given thing
that i've hallucinated doing in the
future i will
have the opportunity to keep seeing it
over and over and over again
so i'll never have to do worse than that
okay
i don't know if that makes sense
whatever uh
okay so the other thing that i do and
this is almost done
is all of these tails which get
evaluated for each of the nexts
if they are bad somehow according to
this ordering they get a score that's
negative and if they're good they get a
score that's positive so that every tale
i kind of have a sense of
how good is this future plan like is
this a plan where i tend to die
on no matter what i do now i'm gonna die
later and i do that so that i can keep
these futures
uh to be to be more or less good because
the better they are the better it plays
and then i come back to this screen i
decided that that purple one was my
favorite
so i commit to it right so now i'm just
like moving forward in the game
i eliminate the ones with the lowest
scores these slide over
okay so i'm about to restart and before
i do so i fill out the missing ones
uh with perhaps mutated perhaps random
perhaps mutated versions of the best
ones okay
so in this one tiny sense this is kind
of a genetic algorithm
i don't consider this a genetic
algorithm but um
you know i guess so and then you have to
extend these with random play so that
you keep that 300 frame look ahead
and that's it and i just keep doing that
um
etc and that's actually the more or less
the core idea of the search
there are some things i'm going to
mention these for posterity and you can
look at these in the paper they're
explained pretty well in the paper
which is on tom7.org mario
uh there's waiting of the random input
so purely random inputs are
terrible it's if if i did purely random
inputs then half of the time i'd be
pressing the start button right
and half of the time i'd be pressing the
start button and a quarter of the time
start button and select button at the
same time which is like no game
that's that's never a good idea so uh i
actually look at what the
what i put what i pressed when i was
playing the game and that form some
model for how to generate them randomly
pretty straightforward
um i also as the game is playing it
re-weights that out that
model so that if it finds that it likes
short button presses more than me
than i did it can sort of learn that
over time and sometimes this leads to
awesome and awesome and absurd behavior
where it's pressing the buttons
extremely fast
i'll show you an example of that in a
bit there's this back tracking thing
which i'm not sure if it was a good idea
but every couple hundred frames it just
runs way back and says
if i play randomly like did i get myself
in a bad spot
via some um by some i don't know a bad
idea
i don't know if that's a good idea but
it's explained in the paper there's some
system stuff here so
there's some clever state caching and
compression techniques to store a lot of
these in ram
and because fce ux is just
relentlessly bad software it has like
global variables called foo that are
fundamental to the way that the software
works
like you cannot make this thing
multi-threaded so
the only thing i could do is make it
multi-process since you have a bunch of
different um
you know processes on my machine running
uh using tcp
the nice thing about that is they
actually run this on many computers at
once if i want all this stuff was just
on my home machine
one home machine and that thing's called
marionette which is a double entendre
that i'm a little bit proud of so i'll
just throw that in there
and now i want to talk to you about or
not talk to you i want to show you a
demo
and so let's do that